as game day continues more trailers are
released and more opinions for me shall
flow the star trek into darkness trailer
debuted the Super Bowl I'm pumped for
this movie for a number of reasons
besides the fact that let me just say
first off it looks great the movie looks
extremely well done and I'm excited to
see this movie I really enjoyed the
first Star Trek i have it on blu-ray
over there that's why i'm pointing over
there if you ever see me in a video go i
really enjoyed this movie it's probably
because it's over there in my blu-ray
collection i'm also excited because JJ
Abrams was announced as the director of
Star Wars that means that everyone is
going to be watching this movie going
this is the guy who's gonna do Star Wars
how is this movie's gonna be and JJ
Abrams man you are such a tease you are
good at that man look at his clip the
hell are you at what fantasy he knows
what we want to know who the villain is
but he keeps teasing us and he's so good
at that you know what I love him for
because I love going into a movie not
knowing much about I love going into a
movie with the surprises still there and
JJ Abrams understands that and I love
that about him towards the end of the
trailer a ship is definitely crashing it
may be the enterprise not entirely sure
there seems to be a new trend in movies
lately where they capture a villain and
put him somewhere and then interrogate
him Skyfall the dark knight The Avengers
it's happening a lot lately and now star
trek to and you know I'm not saying it's
copping off of those films I'm just
saying it is always an interesting
experience for the hero to be able to
have the villain at bay there you're
captured I'm going to interrogate you
but the villain still has a plan going
and it makes him seem like he's just all
powerful person and I really liked that
line I'm better at what everything it's
just menacing i like it i'm excited for
Star Trek 2 i'm excited to see this film
simply because i love when a filmmaker
is able to take something that we
already know and love like the star trek
from the olden days take it in a
different direction it still maintain
that same field which he did in the
first film and now expound upon that
where it just takes a film that was
already really fun and well-made as a
filmmaker you don't have to worry as
much about establishing characters
because now they're established and
everyone likes them and now you can do
stuff with them and take them in
directions that people don't expect and
I'm hoping that Star Trek to does that
I'm looking forward to the movie what
did you guys think of the trailer thanks
for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes shall we begin